akos is there something that you'd like
to bring
up uh I think maybe we it's time we
defend Matt re a little
bit so everybody's [__] on this poor
kid I understand he's a 27y old kid who
out of nowhere blew the [__] up like he
was always doing all right but he blew
the [__] up and I feel like everybody's
coming for his neck and it's like now
people are just trying to get content
off on getting him to respond which if I
was if I could talk to him I'd be like
hey buddy just please don't resp respond
it's only going to make things worse
what do you mean content off of he'll
respond to people making Tik toks about
him in the comments yeah and he'll get
emotional about it and I want to be like
that's what are you doing but I also
know this a 27y old kid still he's young
I remember being 27 you're just 27y old
man yeah he's a but at that level of
Fame you're a kid you know what I mean
at 27 at that level of wealth and fame
you're not mature enough to handle that
M that's like you need to be like like
in your 30s at least to be able to
handle that level of Fame with Grace
male female don't matter let's just say
he's struggling with Fame and the
criticism that that struggling of hise
doesn't matter and other people have
struggled way more with drugs and all
that [__] but he'll just like respond to
comments and then people will start
making Tik Tok content about him
responding to comments like this one
girl this is a clip that we got sent
this morning this one girl made a
comment about how Matt R went at my
six-year-old son who's Autistic or
something and how dare he and on the
surface you're like yo what the [__] is
that and what happened is this kid had a
he had some response to a Matt R joke
Matt R said something about the planets
that was inaccurate this an astrology
joke and the punchline is about Rings
basically and it's a joke about
astrology and this kid loves outer space
so he corrects Matt re in the video and
then goes also you are mean to women
yeah and then Matt R responds to the Tik
Tok and this is all on the surface
saying like hey buddy Santa Claus isn't
real your mom makes money on only fans
something else that's over the line it
says your mom buys you your presents
using only fans money oh there it is
funny over the line a little bit cuz
it's a kid and everybody's going to jump
on but when everybody's overlooking is
this woman posted that video on her own
personal page it's not the kid making a
Tik Tok on his page yeah saying hey Matt
R you so and so this girl who makes a
living on Tik Tok so she says on social
media so she says is using her kid to
make content right and then Matt R gets
which is her Matt R get telling her kid
what to say too the kid doesn't know oh
yeah you think the kid knows Matt R is
mean to women at 6 years old he's
actually six she says six yeah yeah I
mean 2.2 million Tik Tok followers also
wow and so now she's just like now that
he responded that's her dream scenario
her dream scenario is Matt re is really
mean to my kid yeah and nobody's talking
about that part all these people who are
just kind of like hoping to antagonize
this guy this man to get him to respond
so they can make money it's like yo do
are just as [__] and nobody's talking
about you especially this girl who's
pimping her kid out like that like you
want your kid to get told Santa's not
real by some [__] 27-year-old yeah
why does you get some views why does a
six-year-old have Tik Tok in the first
place like that seems crazy it's not his
Tik Tok it's on her page but she still
has him do a video and then this whole
thing she does I don't I protect my kids
identity I don't pimp I don't use them
for videos it's a video you posted on
your page I just again I think every is
in a real hurry to get on to this kid
because he's a good-looking white man
who got really successful really quickly
you think it's because he's good-looking
the baseline or do you think because
there's views attached to the criticism
of him I think people are making content
for views I think the people who are
jumping on board the content and all the
hate from the people who don't aren't
social media uh like mavens or whatever
trying to make a living on social media
they're the ones that are like at a
baseline I'm annoyed by this guy cuz I
feel like he's very privileged he checks
all the boxes of privilege in society
male white good-look yeah that might be
it I I just think that like sometimes
pendulums swing you know so it's just
like a pendulum definitely swung in a
direction that you know pushed him to
super stardom and I think one of the
issues with like getting famous really
fast is you don't
develop true fans cuz there's not enough
time to develop a true fan so like when
you are building your career for 10
years yeah those people have probably
digested months of content of yours I
mean by hour per hour when you like
Skyrocket in less than a year these are
new people kind of finding out about you
but they might not know who you are they
might not know your totality but this
it's this unbelievable Ascension and
like what we saw with him is probably
faster than any comic in history I've
never seen it and it's not just what
happens with with stand-ups it can
happen with a a one- hit wonder a song
like people love this song they don't
really know the artists they don't
really know what they're about they
don't really care about the artists they
really love this song and then they drop
more stuff about what they care about
and then people like yeah we didn't
really like you we like that thing that
you did one time and then they fall
apart it's just easier to cancel so I
think what's happening now is that Matt
might not have the same fervor of his
fan base to defend him because they
haven't had enough time to congeal and
really understand who he is the I would
imagine like a real Matt R fan would
look at the things that he's being
canceled for and go this is what he does
this is the type of humor he has it's
like why are you canceling the guy for
saying a joke that's off color he does
this all the time yeah but these these
people that are new to him that are
casual don't have enough of like a a
background if you will they don't have
like a a bachelor's degree in that
enough to know that's who he is and then
the pendulum swings and then just the
online leeches start to jump on and they
go oh there's views oh there's views in
this guy I'm putting his name in Google
Trends and seeing that a lot of people
are clicking okay I'll do my story of
the day on him okay I can I agree with
all that you don't think some layer of
it is he's a good-looking white dude
sure I I mean I do think that definitely
great jawline great jawline I think
that's some gas on it for sure I'm not
saying it's not I'm a certain there are
plenty good-looking white dudes like Tom
Brady is a very good look you're a
good-looking white
dude anyway so like Tom Tom Brady's a
good-looking white dude that doesn't get
really any CR
criticism yeah I also think that's a
little Sports is a little different
because it is an absolute meritocracy
you win a championship and that can't be
denied and if you won seven that can't
be denied so what would be the
championship in in comedy right he's you
know the biggest touring comedian right
now he's got a net I can subjectively
say I don't think he's good I can't
really I can't do you feel that way Matt
R I think Matt R is really great at
crowd work I think he's top tier I think
his jokes are good I'm not like blown
away for being blunt but it's like okay
that's fine he's a good comic so then
maybe what you're describing is the
distance between how famous he is and
how good he is and whenever there's a
discrepancy there it's easy for an
audience to turn on that individual
for example it's like we use this
Beckham thing all the time like David
Beckham was [__] awesome at soccer
objectively but he was more famous than
guys that were better than him so soccer
purists were like why the [__] is this
guy getting all the credit cuz he's
good-looking cuz he's white cuz he's
male [__] that guy give the credit to
this other guy over here he's way better
we should be talking about him he should
be on the cover every magazine he should
be winning the balondo or whatever it is
every single time and there becomes this
resentment because the success and
accolades feel undeserved and that's a
very normal human reaction this happens
all the time when we feel like somebody
has achieved something that they don't
feel like they deserve we already hate
people that are successful naturally as
human beings but when we feel like the
success is
undeserved then we feel really
comfortable projecting it now in my
opinion it's like people love what Matt
was doing and then want to go see him
you can't be upset at that yeah there's
the like you could be angry as a comic
who maybe doesn't have that level of
success it's not fair to him way it's
not fair to David Beckham exactly it's
like there's resentment I'm sure there's
a lot of comics out there they're just
angry that this guy is achieving all the
success and they've been doing comedy
for years and maybe haven't achieved
that and I think there's a lot of
resentment and bitterness that comes out
and see it and there's a lot of comics
probably celebrating what's happening to
Matt right now yeah and i' also I've
known him we're not like homies by any
stretch but I just knew him on while and
out I think I was a writer the first
season he came on I had like kind of
left being cast but I was like a he's a
sweet kid and I still know him to be a
sweet kid so all the hate I'm just like
what are y'all doing why is this this
Glee that seems to be happening in his
downfall and I understand a lot of what
you're saying I do think I still stand
on that being a percentage of it yeah
yeah I didn't say it wasn't a percentage
did you think I I said it wasn't a
percentage Yeah Yeah okay no I think
it's a percentage I just I think that
like that alone isn't the thing because
I don't think that alone tons of I think
it's the vast minority of it I think
it's just because if for example Tom
Brady is the exact same situation only
Tom Brady is better than he is white
male and good-looking so nobody can say
[__] right and I think the one
difference here is that some people
might go wow he's the most famous
comedian on the planet but he's not as
good as Dave Chappelle yeah so what the
what's going on here why is he so famous
but he's not as good as Dave Chappelle
oh there's a discrepancy I need to tear
that down M yeah all right guys let's
take a break for a second it's holidays
okay it's holidays and holiday dick need
to be good why does it need to be good
because you're with your family maybe
you're with your wife's family your
girls family and they need to know that
you're laying it down they need to hear
you they need to hear the banister they
need to hear the bed backboard slamming
against that thin drywall they got
between your room and uh your girl's
cousin's room
simple as that okay you're having turkey
I know you got that tryptophan in the
system you're tired dick probably
slouching not when you chew it up not
when you chew it up chew it out
headboard smack it against the wall
waking up the whole house okay Santa's
here not coming down the chimney coming
in it Santa's here all the presents we
got a bag full of them all the presence
Santa is here blue Chu is
delivering for you same active
ingredients inside Seattle s Viagra but
this is the chuds one that we rock with
simple as that and you're going to get
it for free all you got to do to have
the best dick of your life all you got
to do to have the best dick of your life
and you're going to get it free all you
got to do is pay $5 shipping when you go
to blue.com use the promo code flagrant
that is it you are welcome no more needs
to be said let's get back to the show
people do a Taylor Swift yep like you
start comparing Taylor to Beyonce and
everybody's like she can't dance she
can't her voice isn't that good it's
like we're talking about Taylor [__]
Swift here so we have this need like
Taylor Swift became this like example of
white mediocrity do you remember this
conversation where was like see white
people just inflate these things I think
after reflection people start realize oh
the show is amazing she's incredibly
talented writing songs and she's a great
performer but there is this need for us
to create Justice in potentially in uh
unjust
situations yeah you see what I'm saying
yeah I I see what you're saying I also
do think on both sides hate and love a
racial Dynamic does play into it I think
a lot of white women see themselves
reflected in tailor a lot of black women
see the best version of themselves
reflected in Beyonce there's like so
that also fuels the love and that can
fuel the hate on the other sure there's
no question that like these everything
race plays a part in everything I don't
think you can find one issue where it
doesn't play a part I'm just saying like
if you could neutralize that
denominator what else would create
change that's fair mhm and I think
that's what most people are just like
kind of afraid to say yeah there just
that most people are afraid to say kind
of what you said which is like oh he's
more famous than he is incredible yeah
and that Gap creates resentment and then
the moment there's an ability to jump on
that there's there's an opportunity oh
you did an offc color joke which is like
a nothing joke yeah oh yeah [__] you
like they're waiting people are like
literally chomping at the bits that the
bull is stomping in the [__] sand
like give me give me a reason give me a
[__] reason I think we can all agree
that he's not making it any better by
reacting to the no I agree with that and
that's again if I could talk to him I'd
be like buddy cut it out but it's just a
mind trip you go your whole life you can
just like talk [__] on the internet just
respond to people in the comments tweet
out whatever and then all of a sudden
within a year everything you say becomes
content and everything you say can be
scrutinized and people are making money
off it like it just must [__] with your
head you're like oh I can't be who who I
was cuz now I'm not who I used to be
like now I'm way bigger and as you're
saying that my knee-jerk reaction is
yeah buddy that's what comes with making
however much money you're making so yeah
there is Merit to that I also just think
to get that too uncomfortable my bun act
today can't my bunion was hitting the
side of the shoe the shoes weren't made
for bunions bro this this is this is
this is a different type of shoot but go
go on I don't remember what I was saying
to be honest the [__] just disrespectful
to this cure here I got work done I got
work done on my foot today I had to get
but that bunion is sticking out today
yeah I mean that's that's kind of I
thought you were a cowboy no I thought
you were a real
cowboy was I was I was I was but also
Cowboys have a different
ho I mean we got socks on so that's fine
there you go bun yeah should have done
this when we got in the house when your
big toe points the knuckle part starts
to like point out because you don't have
enough Flex in it what but uh oh yeah
yeah go holy [__] where do you rank
these one to 10 oh God awful and that's
what mine look like just absolutely God
awful oh my Lord and there's a surgery
you can do for it but I ain't doing that
[__] but anyway that's gorgeous back to
this so yeah he's going through it and I
just think this is what kind of happens
like for example like anytime Beyonce
gets into anything anytime you brought
up Nicki Minaj last night uh Taylor
anytime they go through any sort of
controversy if you try to push at them
they have an army of fans that are
swinging and I think right now it
doesn't feel like Matt has this Army of
fans swinging for him and it's because
as Taylor Nikki and Beyonce built those
fans over decades literally yeah those
people been riding for them for years
it's like a political candidate it's
like yo you are my guy Bernie Sanders
whatever you do I'm defending you know
yeah and not to say Matt hasn't been
grinding for years but 90 90% of came up
so fast and that's not to say that they
might not become those fans they might
and the more they learn about him the
more they feel comfortable with him the
more they believe in what he truly cares
about and the message he's trying to put
out there and like the art that he's
trying to put out there they might be
wanting to defend it but right
now because it's such a short amount of
time they're like am I really going to
go out all out on the internet to defend
this dude that like I don't even really
know him like that yeah when you think
about it yeah yeah if you're casual it
makes it very easy to to be like oh yeah
I guess that is [__] up yeah [__] that
oh he got whatever he said that to a
six-year-old oh I guess [__] him like
there's very few things that somebody
could tell me you
said that would change my opinion of you
cuz I know you yeah do you know what I
mean
like it would and even if there was
something I'd be like he a say that you
know he was joking like cuz I know you
so well you can't sway my opinion of you
M but if I just met you and then
somebody told me you said some [__] I'd
be like [__] that [__] yeah how
dare he yeah and that's the difference
when you when your you know your fans
have been with you a little bit longer
time now get them whatever you can like
I I I'm not saying Matt should have been
like hey pump the brakes I don't want to
be too famous yeah my man's been doing
comedy for for 15 years he's like this
is the opportunity run to the [__]
top with that [__] yeah of course take
it but this is the cost of it yeah and
that's what you would have to explain to
him in terms of responding to comments
and [__] but this is the cost of getting
that famous that quickly and selling out
Radio City God knows how many times you
just got to eat that low key if it
doesn't affect ticket sales or his
happiness or his
opportunities
the the sort of like um the media
attention that comes from this could be
good uh like I there's a version of this
where he's like oh when I'm in the news
it just helps everything good or bad I'm
going to make fun of the six-year-old
yeah knowing that his mom put him there
and I'm really talking to his mom and
this is a news story yeah and this sort
of like you know version of of of
garnering attention you know Kanye does
this kind of stuff you see a lot of
these people who play with volatility
and it really works so there's a version
where this helps yeah yeah I can see
that I mean I think he'll be fine in
general yeah yeah yeah I I again I just
you're making content about how he
attacked your kid while you're using
your kid for Content it's just no it's
corny what people doing but also like
it's corny of comics like there are
Comics that are going to be eatting off
Matt re without even realizing M like he
brought a whole new demographic of
people what I had a friend that did a
show and he's like a you know handsome
is white dude in the city is really
funny and he did a show a girl came up
to him handsome is is kind of a [__]
up way to say it no he's a handsome is
you can just call him handsome well he's
Jewish but he he did a show and then
after the show this girl com she's like
I'm a huge fan I saw your clip where you
know you were you did that joke about uh
you know the the kid and the mil in the
audience I thought it was so funny and
he was like oh you thought I was Matt R
wow like literally like she saw Matt R
clip and then saw his clip right after
and just kind of put them together and
was like yeah I'll go to this like she
wasn't even know thing is like what's
gonna happen is he introduced a a whole
new demographic of people to stand up
comic comedy and then all those people
are going to go look for other standup
Comics yeah it's like you try Thai food
you don't only go to that one restaurant
you going and go to all the Thai
restaurants like food now kind of like a
flagrant type of jokes tells them all oh
yeah that's good that's okay flagrant
comedy for lack of a better word is okay
yeah I'm just saying like so a lot of
those girls that are watching or a lot
of these new people that are into it a
lot of them are women they're going to
go see other comedy shows they're going
to see your clips they're going to see
your Clips they're going to see mine and
it's like this is amazing this is a
great thing so a lot of people are going
to eat off of it that might be resenting
him or jealous of him or been you want
this you want as many possible people
Russell Peters getting the entire world
outside of America to be into comedy yep
feeds me feeds you damn sure fed me
feeds like I think comedians always
forget that comedy's like kind of niche
in the world yeah you know I me like how
many how many fans in the world are
there like 400 million how many people
do you know personally that went to see
a standup show before you started doing
comedy that's what I'm saying like so
this is a good thing it's yeah I mean
like I feel like we've done a great job
of ushering standup into a bunch of
different places in the world they just
don't have Netflix where they could
watch specials but what can they do they
could watch YouTube clips they could
watch YouTube specials bro we went to
Moscow and did a [__] show in Moscow
and everybody there had seen all the
clips and they're like yeah this is the
only thing we could watch mhm so it's
like
we're introducing countries to standup
comedy and then everybody eats off of it
so hell yeah yeah people need to have
the mindset like yo we're all on the
same team here you like it all it all
helps and now there's no more networks
saying here's X number of spots for X
number of whatever we have 24 episodes
of this show with this many roles it's
just not the only way to do it anymore
the more clicks that can be gotten off
of you the more people will make content
off of you yeah just like CNN does it
with Rogan CNN does with Porto it's like
this is kind of similar but I was
talking to this military dude about uh
like alien [__] and I was like what is
happening why is this in front of
Congress and he's like everyone eats off
it and no one gets hurt ah so he's like
so these like UFO grifter guys they get
to make money off it he's like the
Congress people they look good they get
their little Clips off they get their
sound bites they look like they're like
having fun with this idea like the media
makes a [__] ton of money off it he's
like everyone eats too
hot everyone eats
and no one go I had enough you with any
more disc you're maxed out on my bunion
sticking into my hammer
string it's [__] 83 degrees in here
we're paying we're paying we're pay
you're drinking a
coffee it's a hot coffee oh my god dude
unless you have ice in that coffee how
can you say you complain the most about
it being too cold it's too hot and when
it gets too cold guess who the [__] I'm
he's like a medieval
Prince okay but go on go on go on but
it's like everyone eats
hungry isn't it fire that [__] is fire
try that [__] around the
house I do
not dude my girl's trying to do dick
dry dick dry yeah I don't think that
works bro mil
me
mil but dude my my girl's doing this
thing where she's trying to like make
the room cold before bed like she saw
this Tik Tok some Sweedish [__] where
like they like make the room cold and
then you warm up the bed and then you
sleep better yeah they say that that you
sleep better and so I walked upstairs
this sh was freezing I like like you got
a mezzanine bro I know how you only make
the top part coold
son he rises G like yo that whole
partment going to be it's going to be
colder down here before you get up there
we got a heater downstairs we got a
space heater downstairs yeah but the
heat R but the heat rises bro but it's
got to go through a maze stop it it does
ain't no maze it's just up you got to go
through the staircase you know what I'm
saying you got to go through the the
winding staircase double decker
apartment double decker apartment it's
literally ice water just all around the
room that's what it feels like
impossible to just make the hot not part
when you live when you live in the
double
when you got the when you got the upper
decky then yeah it's you know the Air's
got to go all the way around come on
dude I don't know bro little [__]
Abraham Lincoln
B it's a Nook they call it a Nook
technically head shot with all the
respect don't kiss M take that back
that's without do respect the head shot
without do respect the head
shot okay did I heard someone say they
got JFK recently you ever heard that no
that's when you get messy head in the
back of the car oh [__] that's funny I
like that you guys like that I thought
of it what's the uh what's what's the
street he was on what's that called or
the lawn is right next to the grassy n
the grassy
null let me get that grassy n dude we're
overdue for an
assassination God damn bro what the [__]
dude what